what's up everyone I kind of just wanted
to make this video to shine a light on
and give some of my ideas about a game
called planet coaster now planet coaster
is a new game that's been revealed on
III by frontier and this thing actually
has a very tiny history that I kind of
just wanted to talk about before I get
into the main stuff basically a while
ago now which it was actually around the
time that everybody was very
disappointed with Atari and the roller
coaster tycoon world and they didn't
restart it yet Bronte you posted
something on their Facebook where they
said we are actually going to make a
game now and it's going to be called
coaster Park Tycoon and about a thousand
people like the Facebook page which is
really not that much after a while it
just kind of died down but this weekend
at e3 they released a trailer for it's
now the first half of the video is not
really too interesting though it does
have pretty good animation it is not
what the actual game is going to look
like obviously but as we get into the
part where things start falling in down
from the sky and we get the actual
in-game parts and the things we kind of
recognize from the earlier roller
coaster [ __ ] games as these straight
paths it actually builds up what is most
likely going to be the way that the game
is actually going to look as you build
your parks
honestly my first reaction to this was
okay this must still be some kind of
animation like as soon as you see
something like this you need to check
what is actually going to be in the game
and what is going to be just animation
novelties that they want to have in the
trailer but all this is actually going
to be the way that the game is going to
look that is without the animation that
you've seen at the start of this video
and this is why this trailer is actually
not the interesting points and I was
quite surprised by this but really going
through that website is the thing that
really sold me when it comes to being
hyped about this game coming out now as
you go to the website the first thing
you see is just a roller coaster track
like this with the logo on it and where
you can pre-order it and get a trailer
of it now one thing that struck me about
this was that the lighting is so much
better than on the earlier roller
coaster [ __ ] games and on what the co
second world there's just great detail
on the foliage the grass looks great
especially when compared to the earlier
games and the track actually has B and M
connectors now one thing that I'm not
too happy about though is if you look at
the track it doesn't look like a B and
Amtrak this is supposed to be the bien
tract you can see the bnm sit down cars
on it but it's just that the spine is
way too small actually one thing that I
do really like about it is having those
B&M connectors and having actually
really realistic supports because my god
do those supports look great so I'm just
kind of mixed about this it looks great
it's got great shadows and just the look
of this entire game is just very
pleasing all together but in terms of
track realism it's not really the best
thing ever but I suppose that's really a
nitpick when it comes to how good this
thing looks overall now there's a bit of
an introduction over here which you can
all just read for yourselves but one
thing that I do like to note about this
is that they're saying a connected
global village where you can share your
creativity with the world so there is
going to be some kind of online way that
you can share your parks and do things
with other people which is really great
and there's actually some more
information about this on the sites at
some points so I'll get to that soon now
here's where it gets really interesting
because over here you can see the actual
3d models that they are using in the
game which is just amazing and it allows
us to just take a closer look at this
and see what we think of it now the
first thing I noticed about this is that
there's an amazing level of detail on
the cars and the Texas's go quite well
with that so I really have no complaints
about that one of the things which I was
kind of not so happy to see at first was
the fact that the guests like in roller
coaster can three just have buttons for
eyes and no actual eyes but I think it's
actually not that bad since they
actually do betray some sort of emotion
which was really lacking in roller
coaster country one thing that we can
see over here is that this is obviously
a Benham track with a box spine but it's
really too small of a box and the
connectors to the rails still stick out
on the sides and at the top and it isn't
really entirely a correct being Amtrak
and it still sort of nags me and then
there's another little flat right that
they're showing off over here not really
too much to say about this one it's a
bit of a niche theme I don't see this
fitting in too many parks too well it's
not something generic that you can place
anywhere but when it comes to the model
it just looks fine there's a couple of
textures that have some slight
differences in how great they look like
the side is just has a very low
resolution especially compared to for
example the arms in the middle but
overall I think this looks like a
great right and then last but not least
we have the guests and they're called
characters over here I don't know if
that's anything good but to be very
honest I wasn't really happy about the
way that the guests were called peeps in
wala co second three so this might not
be that way in this game I don't know
about that in any case they do look
really good despite having their
limitations and this little dinosaur
thing is just amazing
it is quite cool to see that you know
they're not going with the old mascots
and have come up with a new one that
actually looks quite cute and I suppose
it's just a bit of this is just my
opinion but I just like the way that
this this thing looks this is a little
little teeth and this little button eyes
now down here are some in-game pictures
but these are basically screenshots from
the video not really too much
interesting things going on but you can
zoom in on the small things and note
some things about it now one of the
things that struck me about this picture
is seeing that arrow slash bakoma rail
on the side as a sort of decoration
because obviously it doesn't fit into
these blocks over here these aren't
tunnels but just footers and the car
isn't really too much of a realistic car
it's really just a decoration but it
looks good in its own right and we
actually do get some arrow or bakoma
Coster types in this game because as you
can see in the background there are some
of those roller coasters there is a
revolution and the drop tower and one
thing that I am not too happy about
though is the fact that I see some
stalls and just the same themed stalls
that we've had in rollercoaster can one
two and three now even though these are
really good when it comes to the game
simulation and the money aspect of the
game it isn't really the most realistic
theme and one thing that we've always
been missing in the entire series to
make it more realistic is to have actual
restaurants where people can sit and
actually eat in peace and not what about
walking around the park but other than
that I actually think this is this is my
favorite screenshot the second one is
our little trailer mascot running away
from the little dinosaur they're both
looking very cute though I really have
to say that they do go for the very
unrealistic cartoon style guests but I'm
actually quite happy about that because
I just look good and they look quite
cute I still find this dinosaur thing
way too adorable so this is actually
quite a quite a funny picture even if it
doesn't reveal too much and what I would
like to note though by the way is that
litter bin in the corner right there
that is that is a thing of beauty that
is that is the type of litter bin we've
always should have had in these games
the support work in the background
worries me a tiny bit though because I
don't see any footage the coaster is
extremely under supported and the
supports in general have unrealistic
flanges and no connectors to speak of at
least by the looks of it so I don't
really know what to think about that
only thing other thing that I can note
about it is that little hedge behind the
path looks quite good and the trees are
quite good as well now here's another
picture from the trailer I don't know if
that I don't think the game is actually
going to look like this I find it quite
funny how it had that roller coaster
track in the clouds now is just a nice
little touch now there's not really
anything new in this screenshot the only
thing that we really have a good look at
is some more path props so we see the
curbs on the side of the paths which
look really good and there are actually
some corner stones now I don't know
exactly if these will be based on the
placement of the pots because telling by
the fact that the path is wider near the
camera than it is farther away from it
these curb corner stones actually going
to appear whenever you're going to have
a corner to make sure that the curbs are
going to be smooth and don't have any
edges that stick out or go into each
other so that's actually a very nice
little detail the bench is just a bit of
a simple thing really the lights though
I like the lights I like them quite a
bit and there's a hamburger store called
chief beef so Franti it really hasn't
lost their touch for cheesy names yet
and this picture just wants to kill me
with more adorable dinosaur nests I
might get this game just together this
dinosaur like this dinosaur is mine now
here's another picture which looks like
it came from a Pixar movie but doesn't
actually reveal too much about the game
and this I think is the most important
picture when it comes to how the game is
actually going to look at what we can
expect because this looks amazing and
there's a number of things that we can
prove when it comes to this for example
we're finally probably not going to have
parts anymore that are restricted to
just the grids and we can finally have
some curves perhaps I don't know if
we'll actually be able to get some
curves because the curves that I do see
over here are run the flat right but
this does appear to be just the way the
path is and some diagonals and not just
diagnosed in any way but it seems to be
in a very free way that you can place
them which is probably judging by the
fact that these corners appear in every
once in a while on your linear
we can probably place the paths using a
line - which is absolutely amazing when
it comes to building theme parks because
that means that there is so much more
flexibility when it comes to building
Pikes there's a blue fence with
lampposts around the teacups right and
that actually continues for the queue so
that's probably going to be the new type
of ride queue that with ride fans that
we're going to have we can see one in
the bottom left corner where we have a
more white fence for the revolution ride
and then for the drop tower there's no
fence at all around that at least it
seems to be that way so that's probably
placed on a platform and maybe in some
way it's going to have a different queue
but basically we can probably both
judging by this the entrance and queues
are probably going to stay just about
the same because we can see an entrance
building for the teacups which actually
fits the teacups rides which is a very
amazing touch right there and as well as
an exit little path for the teacups
which also has a little tea cup or a
coffee cup whatever it now this looks
like a ticket I think you shouldn't talk
about that and the revolution also has a
very clear entrance and exit so I don't
know if we'll actually be able to get
some of the more realistic queues that
you have sometimes in theme parks we
which don't really follow this grid way
and don't have an entrance and exit like
that but still it is something that's
been within the ICT series for so long
and just to see those little cute
entrances back that you know I've always
loved the entrances from the first game
and just to see something which I like
just as much is really awesome to see of
course there's the water - which I can't
really complain too much about but I
don't see any reflection of water
it just looks okay nothing really too
special to see over there now beside the
peeps and the model for the chairs on
the flat right which are absolutely
amazing though I do see that restrained
going through the legs of the guest
right there which is a something that
happened in our city 3 and I was hoping
that wouldn't happen in this game but
other than that it looks really good and
the peeps actually show some emotion
they don't look like emotionless dolls
husks without a soul and like in what
the coaster can three and you just kind
of like them despite the button faces
they have a they don't really look too
scary
they look kind of cute so I think it's
okay now in the store they have a number
of little cash grabs right there and
like as soon as I saw this I was like no
[ __ ] [ __ ] or fight what do you think I
am but physically some things that no I
actually kind of cool in this you can
pre-order the game for just 20 pounds
which is about 31 dollars and about 28
euros which is really not that much and
then you'll be able to get it as soon as
it comes out which is really nice
you could get an early bird beta pass
for 50 pounds which is a lot of money
that's like 75 dollars and that is Han
it is 30 pounds more expensive than the
original which will give you access to
the beta version as soon as the beta
comes out but I really can't say too
much about this other than that it's a
lot more expensive than the real game
and since we don't really know yet when
the beta version is going to come out or
not I'll just wait this one out until
then I actually will actually some dates
but it is pretty cool that they're
giving out this thing before it actually
gets released to the public to those who
want to play it before it is fully
released
now here's when it gets great 410 pounds
you can buy a ticket which can use to
create your own guest so a peep well a
guest creator as we had in rollercoaster
tycoon 3 is probably going to be in the
game you can give it your own name and a
guest that will probably resemble you or
whoever you want to resemble is going to
be able to walk into other people's
spikes and it'll appear in all your
parks but not maybe not in all of the
other parks since there will be maybe
many guests that you know can roam
around named after various people but
it's still a really cool thing to have
and it once again proves that the mine
actually be some internet connection
between the parks for 25 pounds you can
join the coaster head club which gives
you access into the private forums and
and I find that a bit over yeah so I
think any way that you could just have
access to this one forum if you've paid
this much money but one thing that is
really cool about this and actually does
make it really worth it probably is that
you get a one-off t-shirt and a
wristband so that is actually quite cool
for 40 pounds you can get a group ticket
which is very similar to the single
ticket except you can join a group and
make that group after whoever you want
it and you can stay you can enter other
people's bikes as well as your own parks
with that group which is quite cool that
one
if that one guy in the shoulder of that
woman is a bit scary though also I feel
bad for kim jung-eun in the back right
there that poor little fella now for 100
pounds which is a lot of money but this
is still pretty cool you can be a staff
member in other people's bikes as well
as your employees and that is actually
pretty cool so you'll be the kind of
person that'll be standing in these
stalls but instead of getting paid money
you have to pay money for it but it does
look really cool and other people will
be able to see your avatar in their
little ships that they open so that's
really cool now last but not least for
500 pounds which is a staggering amount
of money but this is quite cool you can
have a foundation stone in the entrance
building and this means that your name
will be engraved in the entrance
buildings of all the people around the
world which is quite cool now beside the
fun this is though it does make me
wonder whether that's just going to be
one entrance building which really seems
lacking considering the fact that the
earlier RCT Games had so many different
entrance buildings now this as with the
other extra things that you can buy is
going to be checked by frontier so there
is no naming your guests really terrible
things or stuff like that not that I
really expected anybody to pay five
hundred pounds just to troll the
internet but you never know what kind of
stupid people you'll have so that about
wraps it up for this video I think it's
really awesome to finally see such a
game that actually seems very promising
after the debacle that we had with our
city world and ICT for mobile and other
things and this really seems like it may
be a very worthy successor to
rollercoaster game 3 and the highlights
are definitely the fact that we're
probably not going to be stuck to the
grid as much the game looks great there
peeps the guests the guests for what
they are worth do look quite nice and
the 3d models that we can see are quite
good some of the downsides may be the
fact that the supporting system isn't
really perfect but these things might
all just be works in progress and
there's a lot of things that we don't
really know like whether that's actually
going to be abilities for customization
in the game like custom scenery which
really helped roller coaster kin 3
become what it is and even what the
ghost akin to is still active because of
this reason and the clouds is the clouds
don't really look too great to be very
honest I'm not a big fan of the clouds
but another cute dinosaur kind of makes
up for
so I'm okay with that I suppose so in my
opinion this is just amazing and I'm
definitely going to hop aboard the hype
train that is currently just ramming
through the ICT community and just no
brakes and let's just see you where this
takes us because so far this is very
promising that being said though I am
definitely going to still be on the look
on the lookout for ICT world and
politics I am really looking forward to
those things as well so that about sums
it up with this little update random
video then I just wanted to kinda get
out there thanks for watching and I
might see you guys later
I'll redesign